after 30 hours and one full playthrough
I can easily say that Lords of the
Fallen is a worthwhile game and one that
receives a hearty recommendation for me
I got a chance to play a small snippet
of this game early along with playing
the whole thing over the past few days
the devs have been in contact with me
and other creators and reviewers and
they have been using lots of our
feedback to adjust and polish the game I
say all this because maybe me having
this positive relationship tanks my
ability to be objective in this review
but I think it's worth mentioning what
seems to be a really good form of open
communication between developers and
some players I think the industry could
use more of that so I was happy to be a
part of it here and I think it did help
fine-tune the game to be a better
experience for release the developers
are obvious fans of fromsoft and it
shows in the game which really does a
great job of hitting all these Souls
like beats in combat level exploration
and lore to name a few but one of its
most defining features is the new
addition of a second underworld called
umbrella um perfect for Halloween and
the Dark Fantasy setting umbrell is an
ey infested realm that mirrors the
normal Game World you play through which
is called Axiom umbrell gives a greater
depth to every level since you always
have to think about what's going on in
that zone as well as the normal
Overworld and you often have to switch
to umbrell to unlock doors find some of
the most valuable Loot and solve
platforming challenges to either
progress or find new things umbrell is
by far the most unique mechanic
introduced in the game and it adds to
the experience of combat and level
exploration as the game went on though I
would have liked some more new umbrella
enemies since a lot of the enemies
throughout the entire time are just
basic zombie mobs and they could have
gone even further with the platforming
and puzzles in umbrell but it's still a
really enriching mechanic that helps the
game shine and in addition to umbrell
the standards of the genre are done well
too level exploration is as I said
obviously made better by umbrell but the
normal levels are interesting to sift
through and unlock shortcuts in and
there's decent Variety in design with
chiefly vertical Cliff sides ju deposing
with standard Castle levels and the true
Hallmark of any Souls game poison swamps
in these levels there's a variety of
loot to find from core healing items to
consumables to upgrade materials Quest
items throwables to even cosmetic color
changes and this makes exploration feel
worthwhile since you pretty often find
something you can use oh yeah and the
throwables are done a bit differently
instead of being consumables they are
items which once found are never lost
instead they're like spells which
recharge on death or resting or using an
extra ammunition consumable you just
choose which one to have equipped and
then you can use a certain amount of
them normally I'm a bit stingy with
consumables so I usually don't end up
using throwing items much in fromsoft
games but I did use the hand x a ton in
my playthrough here so it was a change I
really liked it made me more comfortable
with using the throwables and
experimenting with different items and
integrating it into my play style which
was melee so it was nice to have a
ranged option that I could use
consistently the levels also weave
together well to make an often
interconnected World it always feels
cool to reconnect to an old area from a
new one so I give props to a lot of the
design here though some of the
connections did seem somewhat low in
utility like there wasn't much use to
them maybe the way I chose to progress
caused this since you can go in
whichever direction you want once you
get a bit into the game it's hard to
judge this until I play through the game
again but during my first play through
some of the connections made me think oh
wow that's cool but I don't really need
to use this I'm just going to teleport
since you have fast travel unlocked from
the main vestages from the start but
speaking of the ability to choose which
area to go into next was a welcome
design choice I got to feel out which
way felt best but I could always go back
and follow the other path if I wanted to
this led me to get some weapon upgrades
that I think were pretty early given
where I was in the game which was a nice
reward for being able to get through
some tough sections and a boss or two
like I said though in making the
branching World some of the connection
did seem either unneeded or unhelpful
but I do believe that new game plus
changes up how rest areas work so maybe
the connections are more useful there
too it's hard to say since I've only
played my own playthrough the one time
and jumping for a moment from gameplay
the environment and lore do a good job
of selling the Dark Fantasy setting
there are a variety of environments and
each changes the feeling of its level
well whether it's snow or sewer there
are some low heavy areas strewn
throughout the game world and there's
lots of lore in of course item
desriptions one difference is that a lot
of the lower notes or descriptions
require you have leveled up the relevant
magic stat to fully read them like the
Demon Lord items need The Inferno stat
leveled which is an immersive way of
doing things you have to commit to that
kind of magic or school to understand
more what the items say about it but it
does mean that people who just hit
things with swords miss out I like the
motivation behind the choice but I'd say
maybe the level requirements could be
lower or add some other ways of reading
at least some of the items and speaking
of lore there are also umbrell stigmas
which you can view in the umbrell world
these are basically moments from the
past that we get short glimpses of lots
of the game's voice acting goes into
these and they do help the stories feel
more real than just reading descriptions
my wishes will not ease your suffering
but I pray my sorcery does in this kind
of game where the main story usually
happens mostly before our character gets
there this is a great way of letting the
player still experience some of those
character characters and story beats in
a more Vivid way so another great
addition to the game here and funny
enough it's through umbrell again it
really feels like a lot of the umbrell
design choices have been big positives
that have helped Elevate the game so far
we've gotten most of my current thoughts
on the game other than combat in general
and boss fights I don't want to do
spoilers so I'll keep my boss comments
generalized for the most part combat is
really good despite what lots of
commenters feared the weapons feel
responsive and with the sfx updates the
devs implemented after the community
feedback they sound all
too it's not 100% god tier perfect
sometimes the interaction between my
attacks and enemies doesn't feel
pristinely polished but it's not
something I have a strong complaint over
overall things felt pretty good the game
also gives a few tools in the core
combat Loop dodging dashing blocking and
parrying you have a long Dodge but
during most combat where you're locked
on you'll be dashing which is shorter
and parrying is a kind of perfectly
timed block which does more posture
damage to the enemy blocks that aren't
par lead to your health becoming
withered but you can gain that back from
attacking so that's a nice interaction
between the different elements of the
combat Loop and it helps to serve as an
incentive to keep the pace pretty high
so you can see that there are multiple
options to use when fighting enemies and
there are a good amount of different
enemies throughout the world between the
Axiom and umbrell but towards the second
half of the game they did start to feel
syy sometimes new enemies were too close
in kind to old enemies like one area
getting an Archer which seemed to be
kind of a reskin of another area's
Archer or some axe dudes showing up in
the beginning middle and end of the game
some more enemies that fought more
distinctly and had unique kits would
have been a welcome change mostly in the
second half a good number of the Lesser
bosses got reused as normal enemies
later on and this was okay sometimes it
felt good but it would have been better
if it was used more sparingly in my
opinion to finish up with what might be
the most important aspect to a lot of
people the boss fights were good too
during the initial event we got to play
against just a few and they did a good
job of selling the game to me
fortunately the rest of the game keeps
up the quality there are around 10 main
bosses I think and a good number of
lesser ones in between them for the most
part I really enjoyed all these fights a
few of them added in some extra
mechanics Beyond just 1 V ons not quite
gimmick bosses but definitely additional
different elements to deal with and I
kind of wish there were even more of
those some of those unique aspects
really made the fight stand out and led
to a better utilization of the different
systems that the game has so I really
had fun with those and that said the
straight fights were fun and challenging
and for the most part hit the boxes
there were some kind of lackluster ones
and some feedback has already been given
to the devs with the people who have
already played the game so maybe those
issues will be curtailed with the launch
but we'll see I don't remember too much
of the OST as being too striking but
I'll consider it again on my second
playthrough to see if that changes for
now it did its job and some of the
ambient noises and music was really good
and a few tracks definitely sold their
mood well but overall there wasn't a lot
that immediately stood out to me though
I think I kind of have that issue in
general with osts if they're not
something like at or Wilds but yeah that
was my experience with it I don't know
if I had any other major critiques of
the game fully fleshed out in my mind at
this point maybe along with the Sami
enemies there was something about the
levels that did get a little bit
repetitive in terms of explore for
shortcuts in a kind of same feel whereas
the levels themselves weren't
necessarily too Samy a few of the levels
introduced Unique Mechanics that you had
to use to Traverse or see everything and
I would have liked more of that kind of
like with the boss fights a kind of
unique standout experience helps
differentiate the levels and generally
it was done well when it was done so I
would have liked to see more but the
game being around 30 hours for a
playthrough at least for me means these
issues didn't feel too great if the run
time was another 20 hours and had the
same issues I probably would have felt
more strongly that they were larger
problems but as it stands they weren't
too major the takeaway from all of this
is that I really enjoyed the game
whereas Li of P went with a bloodborne
airo Direction and a strong story Lords
of the Fallen sticks closer to the
gameplay of the Soul Series in Elden
ring though it does give you both a
Dodge and a Dash and a way of getting
Health back through attacking so there
is definitely its own vision of
development there so all of that should
help give you a good idea of what the
game is like especially from a Souls
heavy perspective and hopefully that
gives you enough to decide if the game
is for you now I'm probably going to get
back to playe since there are some
endings I need to get before I can
release an explanation video thanks for
watching and I'll see you in the next
one
peace